these ethiopian children pray with the
torah
a part of the hebrew bible they are some
of ethiopia's last remaining jews
about 4 000 jewish ethiopians who call
themselves beta israel
live here in gander a small city in the
north
this school teaches children about their
jewish faith but also prepares them for
a possible move to israel
if they learn hebrew and if they learn
about their religion it'll help
they'll create mutualism and integrate
within the society there
and support one another in all matters
better israel members want israel to
give them a visa to immigrate
but some in gander have been waiting
more than 20 years
ashanaphiya safa moved from the
countryside to gander 12 years ago
now he's one of the synagogue's
religious leaders he explains the
origins of judaism in ethiopia
we came to ethiopia because god
dispersed the beta israel into the
cardinal directions so we came down from
egypt
we came here following the shores of the
blue nile others went to america
germany and many other countries
under israeli law jews are allowed to
move to the country but the israeli
government
doesn't view the better israel of gander
as jewish under strict religious law
that's because the government says they
are descendants of ethiopian jews who
were forcibly converted to christianity
in the distant past
many of them actually converted or their
parents converted to christianity
for various reasons and now they are
they wish to return to be part of the
jewish people
they are not considered as jews so they
are they already
live as jews but officially they are not
yet converted so they are not yet jews
ashanath yaseva says this is
discrimination
[Music]
some say we're not jewish and there are
no more jews here
they say we're lying that we're just
pretending so we can go there
they think we'll make the religion
impure but the only one to know the
truth is the god that created us
many of the better israel community have
family living in israel
the israeli government has been
gradually allowing ethiopia's remaining
jews to emigrate under family
reunification laws
but it's not clear when people will be
allowed to go leaving some family split
for more than a decade
being alone is very difficult my husband
was raised by his mother together with
his six brothers
but now five live in israel he was very
sad when they got separated
[Music]
working as akalu moved to gander from
her farm with her husband and children
after someone burnt down their crops her
life in gander is tough
but she's grateful her daughter can
attend the town's hebrew school
with knowledge about her religion she
will marry someone who has the same
faith
and follow the religious practices i
hope she will one day live with her
family and her people
i really hope that for my children
despite the struggle and weight hope is
high among gander's jews that one day
they will be allowed to leave
they just don't know when